welcome back so where we left off is
there was a thousand people who all
needed um let's say a million dollar
loans each and they were all going to
pay 10 percent on their loans and they
borrowed it from this bank you know it's
kind of a standard commercial bank and
this bank says well you know i just
handed out a billion dollars and i'm
getting these interest payments and my
you know vaults are empty i want to have
money back in my vaults or you know i
want to have money back on my balance
sheet so i'm going to sell these loans
i'm going to bundle them all together
and sell them to this investment bank
and now listen what is this investment
bank going to do with these loans and
why is it doing it so let me let me
delete this
so we had the investment bank
so we have the investment bank
i randomly picked the color green but i
think it is appropriate for the
investment bank so now i have
all of the you know
me
that's a little smiley face you know
there's a thousand of me
and we are now going to pay the 10
we're now going to make all of our
mortgage payments
the 10 payment to this bank
this investment bank but the investment
bank they're not in the business of of
servicing loans or keeping loans on
their balance sheets so what they do is
they create a corporation
they create an entity they'll you know
maybe a special purpose entity whatever
you want to call it so they create a
company let's let me make that in purple
another color so they create this
company
and what they do is
they will
take
this
this billion dollars uh well no not the
billion dollars they take their rights
to these payments that they got right
they paid a billion dollars to that
first bank in order to get the payments
from all of these people
and they say you know the rights on that
on those payments right that's the asset
they bought all these loans the rights
on those payments we are now going to
transfer to this special purpose entity
to this other corporation so now
everyone is going to essentially all
their money all their mortgage payments
are going to be funneled into this
into this entity right
and this is a corporation and so what
the bank will do is issue shares in this
corporation so let's say that it issues
let's say for simplicity
100 shares so there's 100 shares
100 shares so what's in this corporation
there's each
the entire corporation
gets the mortgage payments on the
billion dollars in loans right it has a
billion dollars of loans outstanding
it's going to get 10 percent a year so
it's going to get 100k uh 100 million
per year right because it's
it's a thousand loans out there it's
going to get 100 million per year for 10
years and at the end of the 10 years
it's also going to get a billion dollars
right
that's its asset it has its asset is the
right on those those those payment
streams that are going to come into this
corporation and then it has a hundred
shares so if you the way i think about
it you can split this company a hundred
ways and i'm doing this to further
confuse you
so what does each of those
the owner of each of those shares what
does it entitle them to
well it entitles me to one hundredth of
what this corporation gets
so each share
so if i have a share let's make it looks
like a share a stock certificate
i'm going to get 100
of this thing and normally you wouldn't
have 100 shares you would have let's say
a million shares actually let me make it
a million shares because i think that
that's in some strange way more
realistic so let's say there are million
shares
so if there are million shares each
share will get one millionth of the cash
flow stream that's entitled to this
entity so instead of getting a hundred
million dollars every year it gets one
millionth of that so it gets a hundred
dollars
per year
and then on the last year instead of
getting a billion dollars it gets a
thousand dollars
so what the bank will do is it'll take
these shares and then it'll sell it to
the general public it'll you know it'll
ipo it essentially you can think of it
that way and tons of people will buy it
especially hedge funds and pension funds
and mutual funds and bond investors and
uh
and and it's just
important to think about how the money
is flowing so now when they share when
they sell these these shares in this
entity
people are going to give them well
hopefully more than what they paid for
it right maybe maybe there's a lot of
demand for this type of asset where i
get this type of a income stream so
maybe once they sell all the shares they
get i don't know they get 1.1 billion
dollars for them right so this is the
investors
investors
and the investors collectively
buy these shares for 1.1 billion
essentially let's say they pay they paid
their i mean 1.1 billion dollars for a
million shares so they paid eleven
hundred dollars per share
right
eleven hundred dollars per share each of
the investors paid eleven hundred
dollars for each of the shares so then
one point one billion dollars goes into
the special purpose entity and if you
think about it the bank made out like a
bandit right because the bank paid a
billion dollars
for
the rights to these mortgage payments
and it's getting 1.1 billion dollars
what from the investors and all the bank
has to do is kind of set this whole
legal structure up and and service the
loans actually doesn't even have to
service loans we'll go into that later
so let me let me
summarize i guess
just because i know this can be a little
bit of a daunting subject
let me summarize
so let me use this purple i don't like
it's a little bit
anyway so you have tons of investors so
each of these is an investor i know
actually a mortgage a borrower all these
people need to buy houses these are all
smiley faces
these are all smiley faces right they
all need to buy houses and then they
collectively
they collectively get a billion dollars
right a million dollars each and they
each use that million dollars to buy
their house
to buy their relative house and then
that billion dollars initially came from
you know just their local
their local bank
and then
and when when the billion dollars came
from that local bank
all the mortgage the payments the
interest payments went to the bank
but then then an investment bank came
along and said well no i want to buy the
rights to those payments
an investment bank came along and says
well i'm going to give you a billion
dollars
1 billion
and now instead of you getting the
payments i get the payments
and then the bank
sets up
a special purpose entity essentially it
sells a bunch of shares let's say it
sells a million shares
one million shares
and let's say it was able to sell each
of those shares for
for eleven hundred dollars
right from from the investment investing
public
so it's able to sell each of them
formula so it raises 1.1 billion dollars
right so it
the value of of this company is 1.1
billion that now goes to the bank and
now the payment stream instead of going
to let me do a different color
now the payment stream
goes to the special purpose entity
instead of the bank and the bank
essentially made out like a bandit
because it paid a billion dollars and it
got 1.1 so it made 100 million dollars
just for doing this transaction i'm not
saying that's how much a bank actually
would make but this shows you why every
person is kind of
what what they're doing in this in this
value chain and as i said before this
bank also probably did something similar
they probably took some fees or
sold the loans for slightly more than
they issued the loans for so this
these shares
each of these 1 million shares
you know these shares that i said
this is a mortgage-backed security
backed
security and it makes sense it's a
security a security is an ownership
that's tradable in a company and that
company has the right to payments that
are secured uh by mortgages so if
all these people promise they would pay
and they're going to pay to this um
to this special purpose entity but if by
chance one of these people you know that
one of these people lose their jobs or
they can't pay or for whatever reason
the instead of the payments this entity
is going to have the rights to their
property and that's why we say that it's
a mortgage-backed security so it's not
just a promise to get money the the
money is actually backed by people's
mortgages and of course then this entity
is gonna if if this guy defaults on his
loan he's one of a million so you know
statistically you might be able to
predict that i don't want to put too
much stock in these statistical models
then this entity will just have that
that property auctioned off or sold and
then it'll just you know the cash flow
will come back to it
so that's what a mortgage-backed
security is hopeful i didn't convince
confuse you too much my next
presentation i'm gonna take it to a
further level of confusion and show you
what a collateralized debt obligation is
and then i'll i'll do a more
philosophical video on
why these things even exist and why
they're useful and why people may
benefit or may not benefit from these
things